meet pepper an African Grey parrot and
his best friend Andrew gray a human
pepper shot to fame in an Internet video
that had 1 million of us tweeting with
joy at the sight of a bird driving
pepper had his wings clipped and can't
fly so he drives around in a vehicle
invented by Andrew it's only fair that
bird should get cars we have airplanes
ok bird driving sounds pretty impossible
so we went to Florida to see for
ourselves
parrot brains as it happens our
extraordinarily adaptable these are very
intelligent creatures and they can adapt
their understanding and their learning
about their environment they've learned
concepts like different and same small
and large they've learned 50 different
words in the English language they've
outperformed three-year-olds on
intelligence tests not my child my child
is brilliant but other people's
three-year-olds
okay so parrots are smart but how do you
teach one to drive I first got him used
to just standing on this bird buggy and
then I tied fishing line to the joystick
to show him that one moves and he kind
of Sochi ated the the movement of the
joystick with a movement cart and become
curious they eventually was able to move
in a forward direction one of the great
things looking at pepper is that when he
does get a big bold tip the will gets
bit caught in the gravel he's able to
actually work that problem out he can
correct the vehicle in order to work out
what the next step needs to be so
there's a problem-solving skill here as
well as just a a plus B equals C so why
have parrots like pepper evolved to be
so intelligent some of the same factors
that have caused primates to evolve
intelligence have caused parrots to
evolve intelligence they're also very
long-lived and live in complex social
and ecological environments in the wild
they need to discern where they are what
kind of food might be in that place have
there been any risks or predators they
also need to be able to detect one bird
from another so they've got a level of
detailed understanding that is really
very impressive well there you go a
bright bird with an ingenious invention
equals an internet smash